welcome to this video mini corner Melek
own yeah from from Finland yeah we got
them with the Dutch boys not so
comfortable with this opening to be
honest sometimes struggle with main
lines here and then tend to play a funny
sight lines which are not terribly bad I
mean it should be quite healthy to
develop stuff but it's a bit um yeah
it's not exactly the way to go against
those openings but i guess i really have
to to look something up here to study
something i mean in in some serious
detail yeah he's playing as somewhat we
had set up here with bishop e6 and so on
but ultimately it's a kind of a mix
between the stone wall and them and the
leningrad variation hmm ok so we'd be
three on this is it looks kind of weird
yeah this with noisy form g5 might be
might be an issue at some moment but i
can take e four so yeah i was thinking
of this but this move but i thought well
stuff like g phi f might be might be an
issue but it doesn't seem to be be
really tricky so we traded queens there
this is a kind of firm oh he's giving up
e seven wow really ok
don't see a problem with it e 7 is is
very important because it gives it is
the counter play the source of the
counter play him with a 5 which is not
going to happen now okay he wants to go
with chief five we are taking on e4 is
probably not a great idea g5 I can go to
g3 there is there is nothing terribly
bad happening to me if the bishop is on
g3 I mean always have to be aware of g5
therefore and age 58 for that your
bishop is not getting trapped but it
doesn't okay he just takes it getting
the bishop pair and maybe he's some
inform some counter play with F form
yeah probably how do I do that I'm one
porn up how to how to play this it's not
it's not that easy because it is a
completely completely closed position
hmm
would be nice to play G for under
favorable circumstances now there must
be aware of F for undermining d flow at
the moment this is safely protected
there are other general idea is to play
F form and then put a knight on d5 but
it's very difficult to to get something
get something serious in this kind of
structure I want to go f3 and g4
possibly this is my IDM f3 f4 I can just
take so that's not not a problem
yeah I think B 3 and so on this is all
well positioned so that the Queen side
is completely secure and DeForest were
protected so f for its not coming okay
I'm going with this okay that I did not
expect I thought that would really help
me maybe i'm wrong but we going to be
going to see what happens so look f2
there is no okay he might get Bishop
back and night two is six that's
something that I have to be aware of hmm
maybe Bishop f5 actually it could be
weakening could be weakening I should
put the bishop on f5 in a moment well
I'm just running into Bishop age for a
stupid can you be here of course you
immediately see it after you make the
move okay it's that's a possibility not
to win the game really it is after you
basically gave it to me on a silver
plate by blundering e7 and everything
okay it's not easy for black to do to
win this anyhow so we are we're going to
see how bad it really is ok now g3 is
not not on ok
yeah putting trying to do something on
the edge file if I go g3t cuz you can
take with the bishop on g4 that's not
really great but it's a tough to prepare
really
time warning
hmm
yeah 40 seconds that's not really nice
and of course the position is not
exactly fantastic you can still hang on
here but it's not not fun
now if I have no nothing active that I
can do here I can take on d4 probably
stumbled into the tactic I have to
basically move on I didn't see it you
have to basically move instantly all the
time this isn't isn't even so easy and
maybe it is he will he will come to a
sound check
check-check
unbelievable into Bishop h4 it was a
complete catastrophe this game for black
jack he has no idea whatsoever to win
here or what yeah okay we will always
live in on time anyway y-yeah Bishop age
for what a howler just any other
movement black is completely toasted of
course yeah okay so just just something
else and and he's just a pawn down for
for nothing the computer evil is of
course is nonsense yeah it is
stockbridge gives it a 0 0 0 yeah that
sets of course of course not true I
don't know what what kind of
compensation is black supposed to have
him just need to be a little bit
circumspect in a blunder stuff okay the
bishop comes to H form my deaf one yeah
I mean I probably didn't didn't do this
kind of idea with geforce maybe not the
most precise one but but still maybe i
should not take actually I mean I did
not really see this Bishop age form this
idea so maybe I should avoid to take in
the first place and I can play like
rookie to give that one hmm that it's
not so easy yeah
ya know I have to correct you have to
correct myself this it's not so easy I
shouldn't play that with G for this idea
hmm I mean I can I have all gone all the
time in the world to prepare it and
probably this is what I should do mmm
you really cannot do much hmm I mean
this is what it was premature to play
that it said this is an interesting
interesting moment really I shouldn't do
that it's with F form he gets us he gets
counterplay he gets some counter playing
even if I don't take it I mean after
taking the bishop to edge for is a
problem that is really a problem no I
really don't I really don't believe that
black has enough compensation for that
as stock Fisher gives but this is not
just a pawn up no no so I have to do it
differently how exactly so g-force is
then not a well time move the computer
wants to do this like this this kind of
maneuver let's say something like this
and night he M
checking age 60 black will take it and
now the compounds to do this setting up
for e4 maybe also yeah in the right
moment if black is doing nothing or F
formed it's very nicely played by the
engine air force is very interesting
actually because in this in this
position I have a I have a direct no i
don't i get key get skinny g6 in yeah f4
f4 it's not it's a bit it's a debatable
move all of the time because now it is
really closed of course I get the knight
to e5 I mean this is something that I
can always do and maybe it's the right
way to do it yeah like this kind of
thing and then the 925 the not only five
will be so annoying that it may be has
to to millions to take it the problem is
Pawn breaks I'm the pawn up but how do I
win this one possible thing is then be
five yes at the right moment opening up
day far but it's a very close position I
really want didn't want to go with a
form i thought i should open up with g
form in any case this is a pretty good
regrouping a pretty good regrouping is e
for remove now it probably Ricans too
much yeah yeah and he has counter plane
now that set sir I mean look f2 is of
course a joke but it's it's not so easy
that's very surprising Bishop to edge
form so is a problem I mean I can do
this if i go here his playing Bishop age
for so i don't really get to to make get
to to put put pressure on this e file
and here i mean this is this is
something that the computer gives with
with equal play and i have my doubts
still about that that should be equal
but it is definitely a difficult
difficult to win this is a line that the
comp gives check check wherefore wiki to
another is this counter play maybe maybe
it really is it is it's nothing anymore
maybe maybe maybe maybe me mmm so i have
to be far more patient here and and not
allow this one one problem is that this
is really no good yeah it's always
getting the pressure on deform yeah
interesting it was a stupid blunder here
that i played but it was surprisingly
difficult to play even mean even this
porn up but yeah I should have I should
have improved the position I was really
thinking that g4 is the right way to do
it and what I did not see is that he has
this Bishop h4 idea this is really a big
am a big oversight this kind of thing is
really nice I can always go here with
the bishop and this is a position that
you can play very very nicely for for a
long term long term win but it will take
a while but I didn't see that this f4
implies the activation of the bishop
here on edge form okay well thanks for
watching